all right well you know how so many of
us are being asked to stay in well in
Chicago that means they could let the
penguin out at the Shedd Aquarium in
Chicago penguins were allowed on a rare
field trip to check out the upper side
of their glass exhibit this week they
took a tour the empty aquarium which is
closed because of the corona virus
outbreak that's Amy and Edward actually
I think is that Amy and Edward there
that might be Wellington Wellington was
fascinated with the fish
he was absolutely obsessed I think with
the tropical fish which maybe he hadn't
seen probably not very is he's actually
one of the oldest penguins in the
country he's 30 years old Wellington I
love Wellington and kind of obsessed
with him anyway there the video of these
penguins has been viewed millions of
times on social media it's nice to know
that somebody's getting a benefit of all
of us being asked to stay home I'd like
to imagine the conversation they're
having is they're looking at the fish
they're like I'm looking at fish but I
don't feel wet do you feel wet why are
we so fascinated by penguins is it
because of the way they walk I love the
way black and white I don't know what it
is but I love them I like what can Adam
tell you and that made me extremely
happy they're dressed up in tuxedos with
nowhere to go good you're right